borderful staff are going to strike for
10 days over Christmas in airports and
ports across the UK that was just one of
the announcements made a few moments ago
let's talk about them more with the
General Secretary of the PCS Union Mark
Sir Walker he joins us now live from
South London Mr sawka thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon let's just
have a little recap of the announcements
that you made because there are a lot of
them affecting a lot of different areas
one of the main areas of strike action
that people at home can expect over
Christmas from your union
well what we've confirmed today is that
industrial action starts next week it
will involve people working in the rural
payments agency we've then got strikes
in the driving and vehicle standards
agency that's people who take driving
tests for five weeks that start next
week
we've got industrial action on National
highways with road traffic officers that
will take 10 days of action six of which
will take place at the same time as
strikes on the railway
we've got strikes in some DWP offices in
the merseyside and in Yorkshire and the
announcement we've just confirmed
earlier on is the Border force staff
will be taking industrial action across
it's just one port at the moment which
is the port of New Haven but at belf but
at the airport in Glasgow Cardiff in
Manchester in Birmingham in Gatwick and
all terminals that Heathrow over the
Christmas period mark you know the
question that I'm going to ask you next
Mark sawucker you know just looking at
you pointed out yourself in your press
conference that you've deliberately
coordinated strikes for the highways
agency and the national highways agency
to to coincide with rail strikes you've
just told us about border Force dates in
December possibly running into January
so that's passport control so that's air
Trail and road over Christmas
people watching you've ruined their
Christmas how are they going to get
anywhere this Christmas whether it's to
work at a vital time in this cost of
living crisis or whether it's to see
family and friends
well the people we represent who are
striking their Christmas has already
been ruined because 40 000 of them use
food banks forty five thousand of them
have to claim benefits the average wage
is 23 000 pounds a year and yet these
people pay out benefits to the public
keep our justice system running our
ports and our airports and so much more
the government has given them two
percent when inflation is at 11 and
actually it's at 16 for the poorest
people that we're representing people
are desperate we've given a government
dossier we've given a dosage to the
government of 170 pages of testimonies
of our members who are not feeding their
families properly they don't put the
lights on they can't afford to get the
work they are desperate they're in
despair therefore their industrial
action is is asking for more money to be
put on the table so that they can have a
half decent Christmas at this terrible
time and this strike would not happen if
Richie sunak and Jeremy Hunt just
accepted one plain fact it can't be
right the people they employ are using
food banks and claiming benefits if they
put money on the table all of these
strikes can be called off Mr Walker I'm
just going to put to you a message I've
had on social media from a viewer um
called Dave Morrison and you know a lot
of people are going to say look you know
people are in the same situation as your
union members up and down the UK what
you're doing is spreading them you're
making it harder for everyone this is
Dave Morrison he said how does the PCS
uni expect for this money to be paid to
staff and the unions want us to pay more
tax massive pay Rises mean higher and
longer inflation the unions are trying
to hold the country to Ransom I think
that in a nutshell the argument he's
trying to make is there just isn't the
money at the moment the government
haven't got the money everyone on strike
the government can't give everyone a pay
rise it would bankrupt the country
yeah and obviously that's wrong and
that's economically wrong and all
economists understand that the the
current problems are caused by this
government they crash the economy they
are the ones who are responsible for the
difficulties we're in yet they're
expecting the people whether they're
paramedics job center workers teachers
or nurses to play a price that they
cannot afford to pay for the
government's own Folly what the
government could easily do is to sit
down and to talk about Distributing
money now because there's a crisis of
poverty of our public servants that
needs to be dealt with now and that's
why this is a far more serious issue for
public sector workers than just whether
there's some short-term disruption and
Dave's anger should be directed at
Richie sunach and Jeremy Hunt they have
the power to stop all of these strikes
today but they refuse to do so and
that's why we're seeing not just my own
Union but dozens of unions constantly
announcing strikes because the people we
represent are at breaking point and they
they are struggling and they need money
now to pay the bills yeah
I very much get your point you know
we're looking at perhaps two million
workers striking over the festive period
I talked to the General Secretary of the
Unison Union
um yesterday who painted a very similar
picture for for
um those who are in her Union using food
banks living on the poverty line but
just how bad is this going to get
because you said in your press
conference this will escalate until the
government puts money on the table how
far are you prepared to go because the
General Secretary of Unison said to us
yesterday that you know the government
says the door is open and the door is
open for everything to be talked about
apart from money they're not talking
about money
and that is absolutely true and I made
the point today the door may be open but
there's nothing behind the door
um and there's no point turning up to
meetings with ministers at last 20
minutes where they don't do anything to
resolve the disputes
um in relation to my own Union PCS the
action we've announced today uh probably
covers in the region of two to three
thousand members but we have a hundred
thousand members who balloted to take
strike action so there's plenty of scope
for us to escalate further but we know
that half a million teachers are
currently balloting we know that health
workers are taking action so it's
inevitable that more and more workers
will go on strike if the government do
not do something about what is a crisis
of poverty and lack of resource in our
Frontline Services if they sit down and
find the money to alleviate some of this
poverty these strikes can stop but if
they don't our Union is going to stand
alongside all the others to say we have
to stand up for our members action is a
last resort but if we don't do this this
poverty will go on and on and on
I've just had a statement in from
Heathrow Airport um in reaction to your
announcement saying to the public that
are traveling with them this Christmas
that look on strike days checks may take
longer is our conservative estimate of
what's going to happen how bad are
things going to be over Christmas in
terms of if you want the public to
listen and pay attention to what you're
doing and as you said redirect their
anger and frustration because everyone's
feeling the pinch whether you're a
member of a union or not to you want
them to direct their anger at the
government so just how bad are things
going to get
yeah I do think people should directly
angry the government because they have
the ability to stop all of these strikes
straight away
um clearly the action is going to cause
a lot of disruption the government says
it's going to bring the Army into our
airports they're going to bring the Army
in apparently to drive ambulances the
solution is not to try to bring the Army
in to give cover when they're not
properly trained it is to sit down and
recognize that millions of public sector
workers who love the jobs that they do
in serving the public would not be
taking strike action unless they were
desperate and if the government do not
heed that call these action I think will
grow with more unions voting to strike
and more and more unions working
together to make it as effective as
possible okay Mark sawalka General
Secretary of the public and Commercial
Services Union thank you for talking to
us here on Sky News this afternoon